he was engaging in deceit with a picture
of spanish meat
a french physicist tweeted a picture of
what he claimed was a distant star
captured by the james webb space
telescope
but only to admit less than an hour
later that it was actually a photo of
chorizo
[Laughter]
but it didn't fool jimmy he's used to
he's used to sending pictures of his
chorizo
[Laughter]
chorizo of course is spanish sausage
which is just like regular sausage it's
delicious it's salty and one of the
reasons brian stelter can no longer
close his bathrobe
but i was surprised france even had
physicists because becoming a physicist
is really hard and the french are known
for giving up
i kid the french
i kid them i didn't watch the physicist
at the incline said that although he had
originally pulled the prank just for fun
he later saw it as a way to encourage
people to think about cognitive bias and
learn to be wary of arguments from
authority
it was also a really good way to get
people to think about what they wanted
for lunch
klein later apologized for a sausage
picture
see i told you the french gave up easy
by the way here are some other pictures
they took with the james webb space
telescope
here are saturn
saturn and its rings
here's the andromeda galaxy
and here is jupiter
that works
cat do you think that's what he was
trying to do
no what was he doing no he was just
doing it because he's like a nerd and
just kind of bored and that was fun to
him but then he's also good enough at
manipulation that he was able to spin it
yes yeah but he's right i mean you
should i think when somebody is saying
something for position of authority you
should almost
be careful to know that they know they
have that authority and they
they might sometimes abuse it
i fired that a poor authority hall i'd
abuse the hell out of it
you know jimmy yeah if i could tell them
about things in outer space that weren't
there oh i would do it yeah i lie all
the time about space me too what do you
what's your favorite lie about space
i'll just start naming stars yes that's
great you see that that's frank
yes
any other thoughts i i was taken in and
i should have known better because i
thought my god that galaxy looks
delicious
michelle
are we so ignorant that we cannot tell
the difference between sausage and a
planet or a star wow
you know as a spaniard i could choose to
be offended by this chorizo thing
but instead i will choose not to be
actually i think this is one of the most
brilliant things i've ever seen on
twitter because a he's a scientist he he
looked at a piece of chorizo sausage
while he was eating his charcuterie and
said doesn't this look like something
from outer space then he sold it right
he sold it then he kind of backtracked
and said by the way nothing from a
charcuterie board ever appears in outer
space and then finally he apologized and
said and it was kind of an apology it
was more like
you all believed it and you shouldn't
have and i thought like cat i thought
that was the most important part of the
message was always always be skeptical
you know i'm used to this when i go to
the dermatologist he will always go that
looks like it's from outer space
and you just ignore it and it goes away
yeah but then it comes back yeah
sometimes it works if it loves you it
comes back right
stds are like that
i do think that um this you know we
already live in an age of deep fakes so
there is a lesson here where and uh
there was a uh head you know like every
other headline you read now if if it's a
picture of a headline it's like like
somebody has super diarrhea right right
like a right-wing activist has super
diarrhea and it's a new york times
headline and it's like i want to believe
that me too i want to believe everybody
in the world has super diarrhea except
me mm-hmm
you gotta trust but verify i've never
heard that phrase before is super
diarrhea one that's fun
super diarrhea
you pay one price you pay one price and
it comes with a water park
that's with the water park super
diarrhea i'll take the soup
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh yeah
the only show that is the number one
show
but does nothing but poop jokes
that's on you america
that's your fault yes all right up next
a dog's expression can leave an
impression hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else